impressionnant et ça a été partout comme
ça dans tous les quartiers en fait où il
y a des arbres matures des grands
érables peut-être trop grand ça sera une
question à poser à Madame plante après
mais donc des arbres complets des
branches qui sont tombés résultant une
des pannes majeures bien sûr que ce
n'est pas aussi grave que le verglotte
98 dans la mesure où il fait moins froid
puis c'est pas le système de transport
qui est touché n'empêche perfect Gabin
responsable du gros Québec est avec nous
ce ministre bonsoir alors la question
qu'on a tous puis ce matin je me suis
promené un peu puis beaucoup de gens
m'ont dit est-ce que il y a moyen de
renforcer ce réseau-là je pense que le
vigile le dit récemment le réseau est
vieillissant et au Québec le reconnu
aussi que regarde cette année les
investissements du Québec pour le
maintien des actifs a augmenté
heureusement doubler à 100 millions
est-ce qu'il faut aller un chef-lieu
élevé ça probablement madame Brochu le
mentionné mais c'est clair qu'il faut
s'occuper de notre réseau qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait
il y a eu les dépenses sur la végétation
pendant des années ont été coupées
est-ce que ça c'est un retard qu'on
n'arrive pas à reprendre comment vous
comprenez entretien
cette année 40 % et pour le contrôle de
la végétation et on parle du réseau de
distribution là-bas nouvelle comme vous
savez très bien les artistes
stratégiques transmission stratégiques
les actifs libérals les équipements
fonctionnent l'enjeu qu'on a eu
aujourd'hui c'est des problèmes de
végétation maintenant à ce que ça
n'avait investi 200 millions au lieu de
100 on n'a pas eu le temps on peut pas
dire ça il y a une sévérité quand même
atmosphérique qui était pas contrôlable
mais je pense qu'il faut quand même
embaucher le très très bien dit faut
augmenter encore plus mais on a déjà
beaucoup augmenté il faut continuer à
augmenter mais augmenter
considérablement plus pour parce que
est-ce que à chaque fois on sera de
parce que des événements comme ça vont
se reproduire malheureusement à chaque
fois est-ce que le réseau va plier les
genoux les deux genoux ça va nous
prendre plusieurs toujours avant de
remonter
de contextualiser le réseau des
transmissions importantes du Labrador et
de il avait déjà aucun impact un réseau
obtenu à 98 il y avait pas tenu je pense
qu'il y a eu beaucoup d'argent
d'investis là on parle de la
distribution quand on va dans les
résidences il demande ce réseau là et
puis les fils c'est plus fragile les
branches les arbres mais là on a beau
faire la prévention pour couper tous les
arbres donc il faut faire attention mais
je pense que 40% des dépenses vont dans
le contrôle des végétaux la végétation
donc je pense qu'on va continuer donc un
plan pour continuer à rester monsieur
Legault à la question sur
l'enfouissement tout à l'heure a dit
écoutez ça coûterait 100 milliards c'est
totalement irréaliste donc c'est la
position qui ne changera pas ça oui
parce que pour les maillot 120 000 km de
réseau 100 milliards d'investissements
puis le contexte il est au Québec en 90
milliards d'actifs sont bilans donc ça
va de bon sens deuxièmement
donc vous êtes d'accord avec la
présidente sortante Hydro-Québec sophie
Brochu qui a dit aujourd'hui même si on
mettait tout l'argent de la terre dans
la prévention ça va arriver donc les
Québécois doivent se préparer à ces
pannes-là qui seront plus fréquents dans
l'avenir vous êtes d'accord on doit
vivre avec ce spectre là je pense la
perfection n'arrivera pas maintenant à
ce qu'on peut être plus rapide pour
établir le courant c'est ça qui est
arrivé là on va voir le résultat on
parle d'un tiers cinéma
donc on a eu deux trois jours il faut
réduire le temps ou peut-être on peut
reconnecter les gens je pense de penser
qu'on aura aucun Brie c'est peut-être
pas réaliste ok là vous vous êtes mieux
informés que nous vous parlez à chaque
seconde à peu près aux gens
d'Hydro-Québec est-ce que là le tiers
dont parlait monsieur Legault le tiers
ce soir le tiers demain soir et le tiers
vers la fin de la fin de semaine de
Pâques c'est toujours la route réaliste
il faut comprendre aussi c'est complexe
et puis la bonne et plus c'est dur
d'avoir la plateforme c'est important de
comprendre c'est que beaucoup des pannes
étaient pour 1000 abonnés et plus qui
ont été très circonscrit et il y a après
une heure ou deux quand je parlais au
Québec il y avait 400 000 abonnés sur
900 1950000 auxquels il y avait des
équipes qui travaillaient donc ça va
aller très vite je pense qu'il va avoir
un éboulement évidemment les dernières
reconnexion au moins de plus longue ou
derrière nouvelle on parle 370 000 qui
pourrait être connectés pour amende ici
demain matin puis le reste qui va suivre
après donc on peut espérer que deux
jours ça va être terminé on a vu à la
conférence de presse à 13h30 monsieur de
départ qui que vous avez nommé hier en
conseil des ministres comme le nouveau
grand patron d'Hydro-Québec mais
intérimaire pourquoi nommer dans une
période qui est si importante pour vous
pour vos projets hydroélectriques pour
tout pour l'énergie au Québec pourquoi
nommer quelqu'un intérimaire
premièrement je pense que le conseil
d'administration du Québec fait son
travail il y a plusieurs candidates et
candidats qui émergent du processus
c'est un qui est très important
probablement une des plus importantes
que l'humain va avoir dans les prochains
4 ans faut prendre notre temps et au
Québec c'est pas seulement une personne
madame brochez une équipe de direction
donc ce départ a fait de partie je
départ connaît très bien au Québec donc
circonstance je pense à nous permettre
de prendre le temps approprié pour
choisir la bonne personne qui devrait se
faire dans les prochaines semaines donc
c'est un peu plus long que vous le
souhaitiez peut-être le choix de cette
personne-là vous êtes des fois vous êtes
impatients
choisir le bon candidat connaissance de
l'identité connaissance du développement
connaissance des enjeux sociétaux on
parle des communautaires il y a beaucoup
de considération je pense qu'on est
mieux de prendre le temps de le faire
comme il faut mais il va voir quand ça
une candidate de l'année prochaine
question est-ce que Monsieur le départ
il a quelques mois ou quelques années ou
quelques mois plus tard moi je dirais
d'ici un mois et demi
vous avez appris la prudence
parce que la première phrase qui sortait
de votre bouche était pas celle que vous
avez prononcé donc vous avez appris la
prudente sur Facebook on va suivre ça
les gens qui dans certains cas on dit il
fait pas froid mais quand même manquer
d'électricité avec des enfants des
familles avec des obligations c'est
c'est pas simplement
il faut remercier les employés de Québec
c'est plus de 1100 personnes qui
travaillent sur 550 équipes en Outaouais
et la grande région de Montréal et
évidemment faire attention au niveau
sécuritaire il faut faire attention au
fil qui traîne pas l'entrée mentionné
donc sécurité c'est important surtout on
a des gens qui sont très dévoués à la
cause et moi je suis très confiant ça va
se répéter très rapidement merci
beaucoup d'être venu nous voir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]